[Music]
goodbye
general we are ready for launch inform
comrades brazilian fn kosijin
that the spaceship foxhole 2 is ready to
launch
yes sir mission control our mouse is
ready
t-minus one minute to lift up
[Music]
maine
[Music]
time to fly my two eagles
is
[Music]
[Music]
stations are on the air
control system today
the 18th of march 1965
at 100 hours the man
spaceship fosgot 2
was launched into the earth's orbit
we are in constant radio contact with
the spacecraft
today the 18th of march 1965
the manned spaceship fossicote ii
was launched into the earth's orbit
for the first time in the history of
mankind a man has walked in outer space
i don't understand the pressure in the
suit keeps increasing
[Music]
okay
we are prepared to enter the airlock
waiting for you
are you suggesting that i leave them in
orbit their soldiers they're prepared to
die to protect their country's interests
will daddy be here when i wake up again
he'll do his very best
[Music]
[Music]
you